as far as the ltr man so it sounds like
what you said is as long as it's
something that
you know it's my decision at that time
you know we've gone through experienced
some up and downs right there's no
protest behavior it's really my call at
the end of the day right so it's not
like i need to get repo approval from
richard cooper's podcast it's at that
point have i leveled up enough to make
that decision myself and have the
resources information to make that
decision myself so
when you move into ltr type of game it's
it's like um it's a little bit harder
you know if i'm being honest um because
you don't have options
you know like if you're going to abandon
your options and you're going to get
into an ltr and you're going to be
monogamous you're going to spend all
your time with her
right
then things start to change and that's
when guys start going through the beta
tization through a thousand concessions
right and you have to be aware of it
when it starts coming your way and you
have to correct so
that's like a part of game that's a
little bit different you know because
people are like i'll spin plates i've
got all these girls everything's great
options are awesome and then they'll
find one girl that they like and they
turn into a beta male within like 12
months well i feel like you've taught me
and i've literally turned my life around
with just your channel so
i feel like i if anyone's able to do it
it's definitely me because
my business changed my personal
relationships family relationships so
like i i guess i do have the resources
and maybe i'll just give it another
couple months and make that decision
and um
i i definitely don't think it's a
decision that needs to be made today
no you can take your time with this man
yeah you keep doing what you're doing if
it's working for you
enjoy it
you know and be honest about it but the
frame part is the most important thing i
mean like the frame
the frame that you set at the start of
the relationship is what's going to
govern the way that it goes right a lot
of guys start with weak frame i think
that you're okay there but just be aware
of that because most guys will start to
they'll let their guard down they put
their feet up they get lazy you know
sort of thing they might put on a couple
of pounds stop chasing a little bit of
excellence because they're around a girl
all the time like one of the things that
happens to guys when they get into
long-term relationships and even
marriages or become fathers is their
testosterone level starts to drop a
little bit
you know
well i'm on trt so yeah well that'll
keep it up actually one of the other
interesting things that i came across
the other day i was watching a huberman
podcast and i found out that
that women's tears will lower men's
testosterone
what yeah
dude
i'd take the cursor and drag that back
i'm like play that back again you
know another 30 seconds because i wanted
to hear it again if you ever cry
uh i'm just leave the house okay
apparently actually can you go in the
room real quick i'm gonna have a private
conversation with rich can you okay so
rich honestly if she ever cries near me
i'm leaving she's out like i'm just
gonna yeah like the crocodiles here
things it's not good for you right yeah
yeah she's not much of a crier so she's
more of like an internalized
but hey can you shut the
door the dog can stay shut the door he
doesn't have much time please yeah
that's uh
listen that's like frame you know for
those of you that are watching you know
notice how he directs her tells her
where to go you know follow up with this
action that's what frame is basically so
you know notice how she responds yeah
well there's no protesting it's okay
there was a smile on her face like she's
excited to bang me tonight i mean like
we had plans so yeah
i love this guy i love you too
guys seriously
rich i have no problem with your
your your your followers following my
instagram john save dogs but if they're
coming at me with the same questions i'm
just going to literally well i'm going
to send them the link to your book so
you you at least get some attribution if
they do buy it but if it's anything like
hey how do i get the girls i'm blocking
them it's yeah like the answers are out
there like go do the work i i'm running
a very successful business now because
of you and it's like do i have time to
do
instagram all day with these guys now
i'm sorry but
i mean some of the connections have been
fantastic you had jaren on your call and
i i had a private chat with him
fantastic yeah i got jared actually
jaron moff and a few of the other guys
from the one percent and this is one of
the perks to get into my community by
the way guys is like you know once you
start you know start to become a
contributor
um we're we're starting to do like a
monthly show now where we just get all
the guys together on the first monday of
every month and you know whoever wants
to chime in i think last time we had
like eight or nine guys popping in and
out from time to time but but it's fun
you know we just call it the one percent
it's just like all these top shelf guys
you know sharing their experiences i
paid youtube
that is that different no that's like
the channel membership thing you want to
get
i'll keep you on that here
no it's this one over here so if you so
if you go to this link over here which
i'm going to pin in the top comment and
then just get into the community just
give us a basic membership okay and then
you know you'll have access to the
starting points if you want to do the
business stuff it's also there as well
you can look at that as well we talk
some entrepreneurship
you